Dog the Bounty Hunter's daughter Lisa is
married
[Music]
the former reality star tied the knot
with longtime girlfriend lyanna Evanson
following more than six years of dating
the couple's Hawaii ceremony took place
on June 3rd Lisa shared these snapshots
of their intimate ceremony to Instagram
Lisa wore a white dress with lyanna
matching in a white button-down top and
both capped off their ensembles with
flower crowns as she describes the day
of their Union in the caption they were
surrounded by seven of their closest
family members and it seems Dwayne was
unable to attend seeing as he wasn't in
any of Lisa's picks a video montage
shows them saying I do while standing in
the Pacific Ocean
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
writing we stated our Declarations of
intent said our vows and began life
together officially as wife and wife the
heartwarming message turns inspirational
as Lisa shares I never thought I was
worthy or capable of this kind of love
the vibration I feel in my body hasn't
stopped since I met her and if you're
reading this from a dark place know that
your happy beginning is out there
somewhere too even though dad Dwayne
didn't make the wedding he's still
sharing his love for Lisa on social
media on her 35th birthday last week
Dwayne wrote on Instagram happy birthday
baby Lisa love you Lisa commented on the
post thank you Dad alongside a heart
eyes themed emoji
I am a law man on a mission from God
fans of Dog Bounty Hunter know Lisa from
her time on the hit reality series I
knew we'd catch him we weren't gonna go
home empty-handed tonight she worked
alongside her pops and his late wife
Beth Chapman Lisa is the daughter of
Dwayne and his third wife Lisa Ray
Britton also called Big Lisa leading to
the newlyweds nickname baby Lisa we used
to play hide and seek huh remember baby
Lisa yeah okay baby I see you right now
and in this sweet message Lisa's new
wife shared her thoughts about their
special day
Leanna wrote on Instagram I still can't
believe I am lucky enough to be by your
side in life in love and adventure and
sickness and in health I will continue
to love you with every ounce of my being
congrats to the happy couple
[Music]